our next
speaker in addition to being a data
scientist has been in a band for 10
years and is about to release his sixth
fulllength
EP please welcome shic uh thanks so much
Jared for the introduction um so like
Jared saided uh let's see if I can
advance these
okay uh yes so like Jared said my name
is schic it's a fun way to pronunciation
guide in case you need to remember um a
little bit about me so I'm a
computational social scientist uh my day
job I work at the national opinion
Research Center uh one of the oldest
social research organizations in the
country uh and I get to work on fun
problems at the intersection of data
science and public opinion we work with
uh partner organizations ranging from
CNN to the CDC uh outside of my day job
I'm a political Scientist by training
and I do a lot of research and writing
on politics uh Beyond what I and today
I'm going to be telling you about one
particular project in that uh in that
portfolio of things I've been thinking
about and just to set the stage for what
I'm going to be talking to you uh uh
about today um American politics when we
think about American politics we tend to
think of the things that are happening
in the four square mile radius outside
of this Auditorium right like the big
political showdowns in Congress deal
making in the white house but I want to
make the case to you that much more of
American politics is happening in your
town hall okay and not just in your town
hall but in particular in public
meetings that are hosted at your town
hall by your local elected officials
public meetings are perhaps one of the
only venues in our political system
where you the constituents of politics
can directly speak to your elected
officials and shape policy with your
elected officials right it's not just
empty dialogue right um for instance
speaking of the CDC so we know that
obviously the CDC was providing a lot of
the policy guidance around dealing with
the coid pandemic but the implementation
and the enforcement of that policy was
very much happening at the local levels
often resulting in sort of contentious
contentious politics protests uh
complaints and backlash from
constituents this is from a public
meeting in in Boston during during coid
times we know that election
Administration and kind of claims about
election administration were a big part
of the kind of uh policy discourse
around uh the 2020
elections uh but election Administration
again happens mostly at the county and
local levels and that's where these
claims are mostly being made uh and also
resulting in one of my favorite public
comments of all time so this gentleman
here uh showed up to his town meeting to
oppose the renewal of a contract with
the Dominion voting systems the kind of
systems that were uh In Contention and
he like ran way past his time limit and
when he was asked to you know uh when he
was told that he was out of time he said
uh to the to the local official no you
are out of time young man so I'm very
thankful for for this issue uh for that
um and sort of a similar thing uh with
other ISU isues like gun violence and
lgbtq rights right we think of these as
National political issues and indeed
they are on many dimensions but with the
kinds of with the with the partisan
gridlock that we're experiencing in
Congress local politics is increasingly
the venue for a lot of a lot of these
these issues um on gun violence there
are actually a lot of local policy
levers you know restricting uh uh you
know uh uh gun uh vendor permits and
licenses on transgender rights for
example there are cities and towns that
are uh uh doing things like Banning
conversion therapy so there are a lot of
things that that can be done at the
local level and you as a resident can
show up and actually make these things
happen Okay so the issue is that you're
hearing less about it and a reason for
this is that you probably know what it
is the local news ecosystems in our
country
are facing a lot of challenges from
consolidation to under Staffing uh to
underfunding uh you once were able to
reliably hear about what was happening
in your town hall that is less and less
true now and that's really the prime
motivation for what I'm going to be
talking to you about today which is this
project called local View and what it is
it's a database of public meetings to
actually map and literally map and track
this policymaking activity at the local
level in the US and so we're able to
look at all of these different places
all of these different localities in the
us and we're able to actually literally
look at the speech uh uh in public
meetings across all of these places over
time and we can see things like climate
change you know religious freedom uh
business business ownership you know
lgbtq rids gun bonds all of these things
come up in public meetings and we're
able to track who talks about them how
they talk about them and we're able to
map this over time um you don't just
have to take my word for it because as
of this morning you can actually play
with this data yourself if you go to
local view. net uh you can not only play
with this data but you can do things
like run correlations with key things
like population size household income
and you can download this data as well
uh and and and of course you can uh look
track Trends over time like you'll see
here you can track things like mentions
of of Co over time so I really encourage
you to do
that so to kind of go behind the scenes
here of how we built this thing and so
we being um kind of my collaborator on
this project Tyler syo Simco he's a
political scientist he's awesome you
should check out his work um and if you
want more details about what I'm about
to show you we actually published this
uh database in nature scientific data
you can hear you can kind of read more
details about what I'm about to show you
um but there's kind of five steps to
this process of how we how we built this
database so we start with the universe
right we start with a sampling frame of
all municipalities in the US which we
get from the Census and really the whole
reason that this is possible is that
many municipalities if not most most
municipalities actually live stream
their meetings on YouTube and so YouTube
is the main source of these meetings and
we go through all of these places and we
create these queries of the place name
and all the possible Municipal
governments that could belong in that
place and we actually went through we
had this horrible Excel spreadsheet that
we went through and actually manually
mapped places to their YouTube channels
and once we did that we were able to
actually go through and download the
videos for all the public meetings from
those channels uh the transcripts which
uh YouTube often does automatically but
also like a lot of city clerks will have
the unfortunate job of having to try
transcribe the meetings in real time um
and we're also able to get things like
metadata right like you know what this
is right it's like the description of
the video there's also descriptions for
the channel these are all very useful
things to know and they're useful to
know to uh help us identify the the the
the place and identify the type of
government which is important and also
identify when the meeting took place
they they are not all you know the the
date that the video is uploaded is often
not the same as when the meeting took
place okay so getting kind of into the
weeds there but the reason why this is
uh important is that we can now you can
now take this database and you can merge
it with all sorts of things like uh you
know population density which you can
get from the ACs again you can merge our
database with all of these fun things
population density for example census
demographic data election outcomes at
the local level uh and Co counts which
are uh um are available at the local
level and you can do all sorts of things
all of which you can do on our dashboard
now by the way things like descriptive
analysis of the text the speech that is
being used at these meetings
correlational analyses and overtime
analyses as well and just to kind of
peek into the the text stack that we're
using here uh this is Blasphemous but we
we are actually using a little bit of
python uh in particular the Google The
Google apis to actually pull from
YouTube ion's actually a little bit
better for that than our uh and we're
using this package called Web VT which
allows us to pull the transcripts and
kind of structure structure the
transcripts and get time stamps for
words that are being said in real time
okay so these are all kind of friendly
character that we uh all know and love
um so tidy census is this fantastic
package that actually allows us to get
the the sampling frame of all places I
want to give a big shout out to power
join uh which besides having a really
cool hex sticker um was very crucial for
us to turn a thousand line script into
like a 20 line script of of multiple
joins happening in sequence as we're
trying to find for each video what's the
place that it it matches to so I'd
highly recommend you check out pyate
join if you haven't already um you you
probably know these other two characters
arrow and shiny AR so all of our data as
of a couple of days ago is is is stored
in parket format uh and our entire
dashboard is built in shiny as you may
have guessed couple other characters
that you may also know and love or not
love um duck DB is actually the way that
we're able to not turn this project into
like a five server 3 AWS instance
sprawling Behemoth that no one wants to
work on it's all on one server and
there's no server there's really no
there's no layer between the par files
and the dashboard thanks to duct TV our
app is hosted on shiny apps thank you
POS it uh and the underlying data that
you can actually access and download
right now if you want is hosted um at
the Harvard data verse project it's a
it's a repository for academic data um
which I'd recommend that you check out
as well uh okay just to show you how
easy it is to analyze this data all you
have to do is you have to create an
account on the data verse on the Harware
dataverse you get your token you install
two packages if you don't have them
already and voila you can just read in a
slice of your of the data the parket the
data in parket format and the Repository
a data frame for
free
okay so what can local view actually
tell us about local politics why is this
database
useful so we've been doing research with
this database for a couple years now and
I just want to share a couple of things
that we we uh you know kind of
consistently find some of these are you
know not necessarily pathbreaking
but one issue attention changes over
time and context and this is sort of
obvious right so if we recall uh uh you
know my that gif was showing mentions of
coid over time and indeed mentions of
coid
unsurprisingly um have decreased over
time and before I get a toughy award
there's a there's a um there's another
version of this plot that has percentage
of meetings over time so you know that
I'm not trying to fool you you can look
at percentage of meetings over time
again unsurprisingly attention to CO as
a percentage of all meetings over time
is also also declined but something that
might surprise you is that attention to
co itself is actually correlated with uh
household income uh which is sort of
funny because in a lot of place you know
the epicenter of coid in the local level
was not you know wealthy wealthy
municipalities in the US so that that's
kind of interesting that's kind of
surprising if we look at abortion so
abortion is kind of an interesting issue
it's an example of kind of burst the
attention to uh you know a mostly sort
of national or state level uh policy
topic this first burst happened after
all of the kind of big state bans that
uh abortion kind of total bans that had
happened in the South and this other
Peak here is after the Dos decision
which you may have guessed and so you
had these like bursts of attention to to
to abortion um and you can see here that
that these mentions at the place level
are actually negative correlated with
with household income median household
income in that
place okay and to take a third issue uh
if we look at attention to policing this
is an issue that's only been growing in
attention at least somewhat steadily
over time and there doesn't seem to be
that discernable of a correlation with
household income there's a SL there's a
slight positive correlation with kind of
how wealthy a municipality is and how
much attention is paid to police I
encourage you to query these on your own
because you can actually see excuse me
specific examples of mentions of these
topics in these various places okay so
to kind of have a more system level view
of what's going on in local politics and
to kind of think about the politics part
of this so this is I'm going to show you
one analysis that we we did a couple
years ago and basically the takeaway is
that Democratic cities and Republican
towns govern differently which you
probably already know but I'm going to
show show it to you in a kind of nice
way using our data so what I did is if
you're all familiar with topic models I
fit a topic model to our data okay so
topic model did all the topic model
stuff label the topics validate the
topics I took all of our towns all the
places all the governments in our sample
and I looked at the distribution of
topics that are discussed in those place
places in those public meetings so
you're going to see here are a bunch of
dots that are places and what you're
going to see is a sort of principal
component grid of those topics and the
reason to do this principal component
analysis is to see which topics are
correlated with each other okay so a
town that's over here on the far right
corner a town that's over on the far
left upper corner they're very different
in the topics that they uh that that are
brought up in meetings okay and then I'm
also going to show you the topics that
kind of explain that difference between
a town on the far right and the town on
the on the far left and uh just to
complicate things further I'm gonna
actually color each of these places by
their Republican vote share uh their
average Republican vote share over this
sort of 10 year 10 year
period And so what you
see is a couple of things so first we
can see the topics that Happ happen in
like the different topics that really
explain the spread in issue attention in
local politics there are places that
talk a lot about housing a lot about
kind of neighbors and Transit and biking
they're very different from the places
that spend a lot more time talking about
cars motor vehicles that talk about the
roads that talk about you know
unemployment okay so those are those are
very different kind of of places and you
can see here that the most democratic
cities in our sample
Philadelphia uh um you know Austin these
like big kind of Metro hubs they just
talk about different things than like
the smaller places do right Social
Services attention to elections
Community uh these things kind of show
up more in Democratic big cities than
they do in these smaller places that
tend to be more about kind of making
sure that the trains are running on time
the streets are cleaned sort of
different style of governance than you
see in these big cities that focus a lot
more on redistributive
policy okay there's a great quote that
New York City the governance style in
New York City is is closer to Congress
than it is to you know your suburban
Hometown I think this plot does a a good
job of sort of showing
that okay and also if you want to read
the paper behind this figure uh you can
you can do so at that that Euro
okay so that's basically it what's next
for for me is or rather for you is one
you're going to go home and you're going
to start your own project with local
view tonight um you're going to read our
research that uses this data um you're
gonna you're going to chat chat with me
and like all my tweets on uh on the
platform that is that formerly known as
Twitter uh and also um a new project is
underway which is called District view
uh some of my collaborator actually in
in the audience here and you're going to
you're going to stay tuned for this and
and keep an eye out for that so that's
all I got thanks so
much